please welcome the founder and CEO of
harmonics Alex regalis since we released
the first dance central back in 2010
fans have danced to over 220 million
songs and for the past four years
Harmonix has been delivering high
quality innovative motion gaming
experiences for Kinect on October 21st
we're excited to release Disney Fantasia
music evolved for Xbox 360 and Xbox one
in this game we've created a world where
music and magic are one where you'll
become a Sorcerer's Apprentice and remix
your favorite songs through expressive
motion gameplay but since the launch of
the Xbox one our fans have been asking
us when are you bringing back our
favorite dance franchise well the wait
ends this September with Dance Central
spotlight an all new digital only title
available exclusively for download on
Xbox one with a soundtrack of
chart-topping hits and new technology
that allows us to get new tracks into
the game much faster than ever before
you'll be dancing to the hottest hits of
the moment week after week so dance to
top hits and dance central spotlight and
explore a world of music and magic with
Disney Fantasia music evolved only on
Xbox this fall see you at e3
you